seven seconds into the game you and
LeBron chippy what was going on there uh
it's funny because prior to that we were
in practice and I think I was challenged
in the way of saying like you be you're
a physical person but like like I don't
think anybody fears you intim is
intimidated by you and I was in a way
like in that practice I kind of like
took it out on the guys in practice and
um during that day that next game I
didn't even like that wasn't an
intentional thing like I remember I just
stood in front of him and kind of stood
him up and then he tried to run through
me and so that's when like kind of I
looked back to that moment where they
challenged me and I was just like about
to run through me so I threw my shoulder
into him and Braun neither one of us
were like ready to fight or move on past
it but it was like okay like he was kind
of taken a back by it like wait like
normally people would either be
intimidated or like be like move out the
way like stuff like that cuz he's a big
dude like I'm not g to say that hit
definitely when he hits you if you feel
it so when I did it back like all the
referees were surprised too and we just
kind of like kind of kept walking as if
nothing happened and we got double text
for it when I don't think anything was
really going on it's just the league you
know League how it is now so uh but from
there like from the rest of the game it
was just a physical bang bang game and
you know if you asked Brun about the
moment I would love to hear his response
on what he thought initially like after
the game like cool but like initially I
would love to hear those yeah like that
initial bump was probably like a well
this is really interesting to me because
I would love for you to talk about the
importance of not backing down to LeBron
James because I think that however you
decide to react or not react in those
moments is obviously judged by fans they
are going to have like a hypothesis on
it but LeBron does too so what is that
that you have to think about in those
moments yeah for me like I've always
been big on never backing down from
anyone and that's how I kind of live my
life is that like like no matter what
standing or person you are like I'm
willing to speak up or like be a guy
that's going to not be pushed over
around like and there's definitely going
to be a level of respect but not going
to ever be you know pushed around and
looked at and I think that comes from a
guys of level of respect back too
because like anytime I I've have jerseys
at my house and I tell whether it's the
player I ask or Stars whoever it is I
say until you respect me as a player
like I don't want your like don't give
me your jersey and the day that you
respect me like you give me your jersey
and that's like that's going to be my
signal of saying like Okay I earn this
guy's respect and like I'll have to
continue like proving and showing why I
earned it later as a career goes on and
I think I I ended up getting bronze
Jersey that following like week or like
when we played them next because I asked
Marie and I was like listen this is what
I tell people all the time I think
during that game we didn't have the
conversation of course cuz he was
probably pissed but I text ke said look
this tell him this blah blah blah and
then that's when I got it so I was like
that
felt cool to me because for a guy of his
standing and stature and and the career
he's had like to earn a person's respect
is is going to be huge for me wow so he
related to LeBron that he wants the
Jersey but he only wants that Jersey if
you respect him and soon enough you got
the Jersey yeah what did that mean to
you it meant a lot because you know it's
Braun like I'm not I'm not going to be
like this humble or like this not like I
grew up watching this dude you know like
he's um one of the best players ever if
not the you know can arguably one the so
um I look at it and I'm like um pretty
it's pretty cool to be able to have a a
written like not just a signature but a
note on the jersey in my house like
that's something out my my friend back
home I FaceTime that night I was like
bro you're not going to believe
this